翻訳: Shiho Nakamura
校正: Shoko Takaki
（かつおぶしを削る音）
（お湯を注ぐ音）
美味しいおだしが
できあがりました
こんなに一瞬で簡単に
うまみをとることのできる
このおだし
日本にはこんなに
素晴らしいものがあります
うふっ 美味しいです
（拍手）
かつお節削り機で
かつおを削ったことが
あるという方
手を挙げて頂けますか？
おぉ！なんか意外と[いらっしゃる]
すみません 明るくして頂いて
これは趣味で
作ってもらったんですけれど
スワロフスキーで
ちょっとギラついていますけれども
こちらもお友達の
尊敬する先輩に作って頂いて
蛇皮を張ってもらいました
勿論こちらは
外側と関係ありませんので
これももちろん
削ることができます
無くしたら大変ですね
一生ものです
私はおだしのことを
主にやっているのですが
専門家というわけではありません
一人でも多く[の人]に
このおだしの素晴らしさ
美味しさを伝えたいなぁと思って
それだけの活動をしています
おだしの原料ですね
材料ですけれども
主には代表的なものは
昆布
今 削りましたかつお
これ世界一固い食べ物です
気をつけないと 取り扱い注意
あとはシイタケですね
あとはもちろん氷見の煮干し
（拍手）
こういった材料が
主なんですけれども
他にもたくさんたくさん
おだしの材料というのはございます
それこそ各地域に特色豊かな
さまざまなおだしが
おだしの原料がございます
よくですね 質問されるんですよ
おだしのことをやっていると
「正しいおだし」の取り方を
教えてください
と言われるんです
そんなものは
この世に存在しないんですね
「正しいだし」というものはありません
もしあるとすれば
自分自身や家族、お友達が
「あれ なにこれ？美味しい！」って
言ってくれる味
それが「正しいおだし」なんだと
私は思います
人の生き方もそうで
すべてのことに
正しいことというのは
私は無いと思っています
今日 来られた皆様
皆さんおひとりおひとり本当に
違う素晴らしいもの
一人一人違った素晴らしいものを
お持ちでいらっしゃる
やっぱりその人が
生きていくっていう上で
大切なことっていうのは
その違いを認めあって
和すること
だと私は思うんですね
すごくおだしの精神に
通じることだと思っています
例えばですね
私が今日
こちらの登壇を
できなくなったとします
でも代わりがいるんですよね
代わりの方が
登壇されると思います
総理大臣 たとえば市長さん
社長さん
ほとんどの肩書きの方は
全て代わりがききます
ですけれども絶対に
代わりのきかないものが
その職業が
この世に１つだけあります
それはお母さんです
私が「おだしプロジェクト」と
いう活動を始めたいと思ったきっかけは
このお母さんという仕事が
ほんとにこの世で一番一番
素晴らしいことだ
素晴らしいお仕事だ
ということを
子育てをしているお母さんに
伝えたかったからなんです
誰もがですね お母さんから
生まれてきます
うっかりお父さんから生まれちゃいました
という方は今日いらっしゃらない
大丈夫ですよね？
私ももちろん母親 [に]ですね
先ほどちょっと電話を
してまいりました
たぶん「TEDx」って言っても
分からないと思ったので
テレビに出るかもしれない
ということを
ちょっと話しましたら
「差し入れを持って行くよ」
って言われたんです
でもあのまぁ 当日ですし
富山ですから
大丈夫ですよ
っていうことを言いましたらですね
「やぁ富山かぁ お母さんが
生きている内に何回くらい行けるかな」
って言ったので
どうやらですね 悪いことをして
テレビに出ることが
決定したと思ったみたいで
（笑）
それでも犯罪を犯した
ということが分かっても
差し入れをちゃんと
持って来ようと思ったのだと
本当に母親っていうのは 実の生みの母親って
いうのはありがたいなと思いました
やっぱり
お母さんというのは本当に
たった一人なんですね 生みのお母さんです
私はそのお母さんっていう仕事が
すごいなあと思うのはですね
やっぱり命がけで
子供を産んでいるということですね
私は44歳なんですが
子供はいません
なので 子どものいるお母さんを
この子どものいない私が
少しでも何か
子育てをしてない私の時間を
何かこう
お手伝いできることはないかな？
そうやって
何のお手伝いできるだろうって
思ったときに
お母さんが本当に
自分の仕事に誇りを持ってほしい
そういうことを
みんな実は思ってるんだ
世界中のみんなが
思ってるんだということを
私が代わりにと
言ったら変ですけれども
代表してお伝えできる
それをきっかけに
できる活動はないかなと思って
こちらのおだしを選びました
私は思うのですけども
国づくり
この日本に生まれ育って
国づくりというのは
人づくりだと思うんですね
なのでその
お母さんというのは
国をつくるための
本当に要である 人をつくる仕事
っていうのをしている
いわばもう
人づくり国づくりの
プロフェッショナルだと思っています
なんでそう思ったかには
理由があります
私は教員をやっていたんですね
その時にたくさんの
子どもたちと関わりました
本当にあの
やんちゃという表現が
ちょっと
まろやかすぎるんですけれども
まあ行動力の豊かな子供たち
（笑）
放映されるんで
気を遣っていますけれど
そういった子どもたちと
関わる中で
本当はみんなお母さんが
好きなんだなってことがすごく分かる
エピソードがあったんです
やんちゃすぎて救急車で運ばれることに
なった子がいたんですね
私に連絡が来ましたので
私が付き添いで
救急車に乗ったんですよ
いつもはですね ほんとに
お母さんのことなんて
「あんなやつ」とか
まぁお母さんという
言葉も言わないんですね
「あんなやつ」とか
「家に帰りたくない」とか
「メシがまずい」とかですね
そんな悪態をついていた子が
意識もうろうとしている中で
「お母さん お母さん」って言って
涙を流しながらですね
本当にこう無意識に
「お母さん」[って]叫ぶんです
ああ やっぱり
みんなお母さんに愛されたい
すごく「好きだ」って言ってほしい
抱きしめてほしい
だけどもそれが「愛してほしい」って
素直に言えなくて
様々な行動に走ってしまう
お母さんもそれを
望む望まないに関わらず
受け入れなくてはいけない
私はそれはとてももったいない
すれ違いだと思うんですね
私は「愛情料理研究家」という
肩書きを名乗っています
ほんと申し訳ないんですけど
勝手に名乗ったんですよ
誰も推薦してくれたわけではないのに
自称なんですが
「愛情料理研究家」と言ってもですね
料理自体を
研究しているわけではないんです
もちろん栄養素のことなんて
何にも分かりません
ですけども
私は子どもに必要なのは
もちろん
私たちにも必要なのは
お母さんが
手間暇をかけてくれた
「あの料理」っていう
あったかい記憶がよみがえる料理
私はその料理のことを
「愛情料理」と呼んでいます
虐待をされていた子を４カ月ぐらい
家で預かったことがあるんですね
何の食べ物が好きか聞いたら
「カレーが好きだ」って言ったんです
もう私はですね
ありとあらゆるコネを駆使して
コネクションを駆使してですね
無農薬野菜仕入れました
スパイスもですね
インドの方の知り合いのつてで
無農薬のものを全部仕入れました
あのゴリゴリ削るやつも買いました
そして インドのそれこそ
本格的なカレーを作る人に
作り方を聞いて
いやもうこれ
最高のカレーできあがった
その子に出すんですけど
まあ「おいしい」と言って
食べてくれたんです その時は
そしたらその夜ですね
なんかこう
すするような声が聞こえたので
なんだろうなと思って
「どうしたの？」って聞いたら
「お母さんの作ったカレーが食べたい」
って言うんですね
「えぇ？！」って
あんなに虐待をされてきていましたから
その当時 私も今よりもっと
心が狭くてですね
虐待をしたお母さんにちょっと腹が
私も立っておりまして
そのお母さんが作ったカレーが
食べたいということで
すごくビックリしたんです
で「お母さんのカレーってどういう
カレーだったの？」と聞いたらですね
なんとあの銀色の袋に入って
こう絞りだすものに
グリーンピースの
パカンと開ける缶を入れて
レンジでチンしたもの
らしいんですよ
「それがいいの？」って言って
一応おんなじものを作ったんですけれども
「味が違う」って言ったんですね
よくよく話を聞いたら
唯一食卓でお母さんと向かい合って食べた
料理というのがそれだったんです
いや私はもうお母さんには
どう頑張ってもかなわない
もう金額的には
私の方がずっとかけてるわけですよ
手間も能力もいろんな人の
コネクションを介して
「わあ もうこれは究極のカレーだ」
みたいな
自負で出したカレーが
やっぱりお母さんの味には
かなわないんですね
私はその
日本人として
ちょっと恥ずかしいなあと
思ってたことがあったんです
そもそも私はちょっとこう生まれた時期が
第２次ベビーブーム―
すごく人数の多い時で
昭和47年生まれですので
受験とかそういったものの
最盛期というかですね
その時にやっぱり
いい大学に入ることだったり
いい会社に入ることだったり
そういうことに重きを置いていた
時期も確かにあったんです
ですけどもやっぱり
その教員になって
そういった
子どもたちと関わる中で
あぁ 食べることって本当に大事なんだ
っていう当たり前のことに
ようやく気づいたんですね
食べたものでしか
身体ができないということ
それが本当に
私は分からないでおりました
外のいろんな情報に
入ってくる情報に流されて
本当に大事なものを見失っていたんですね
多分ご覧になった方も
いらっしゃるかと思います
『はなちゃんのみそ汁』
という映画ですね
今やっておりますけれども
こちらのはなちゃん
当時５歳の時の写真です
主人公の安武千恵さんという方は
乳がんで亡くなっておられます
その千恵さんがはなちゃんに
当時５歳のはなちゃんに
お味噌汁の作り方を教えたんですね
かつお節を削って
お豆腐を手の上で切って
だしの取り方から
きちんと教えました
今 はなちゃんは中学生
もう「はなさん」ですね
中学生になっておりますけれども
今でもお父さんの安武信吾さんに
毎日お味噌汁を作っています
これは千恵さんが
はなちゃんに与えた
「愛情料理」だと私は思っています
私は「愛情料理研究家」という風に
名乗っていますけれども
本当に伝えたいことっていうのは
さっき言ったように１つだけなんです
お母さんというこの仕事
本当に誇りを
持ってほしいって思うんです
命がけで生んで
もう命と引き換えだったわけです
千恵さん
こうやってその命と引き換えに生んだ
こういうことができるっていうのは
本当に生みのお母さんしかいない
こんなに
素晴らしいことをしているのに
お母さんってそれだけで
輝いていると思うんですよね
子どもを生んで
命がけで生んで育てている
それだけですごく輝いて
家族の中でキラキラしているのに
なんかその今の風潮って
例えば ほかのよそのお母さんが
こう雑誌に載ってた
キラキラしている
なんかインタビュー受けてた
そんなほかの人のこととか
本当にどうでもよくないですか？
全然知らない人に
よく見られることなんて
何にも意味がないと思います
お母さんは本当に自分の子ども
旦那さんそして周りの友人
そういった中で本当に笑顔で
毎日毎日子どもに愛情を注ぐ
家族に愛情を注ぐ
それがお母さんのキラキラだと
私は思っています
すごく輝いています
そういうお母さん
私 思うんですけど
あぁ私映ってた
ビックリしました（笑）
すみません（笑）
この画面って
だいたい四角いですよね―四角い
テレビにしろ
インターネットを見る
スマートフォン、パソコンの画面
四角い画面
この四角い画面の中に私は
本物なんかひとつもないと思っています
例えばこのかつお節です
これ一本作るのに半年ぐらいかかるんですよ
そのかつお節も
例えばこの画像を観て
画面を観て
あぁなんか
かつお節って固そうだな
頭ではわかっていても やっぱり
手で触らないと分からないと思います
そして削った時の感触ですとか
すごい芳香な香り
口に入れたときの
「はぁ」って安心する味
これはですね 絶対画面では
分からないことなんです
手にとってみないと
絶対に分からない
そんな外の情報に
惑わされて
足元を見なくなるというのは
私はとてもとても
もったいないことだと思っています
日本にはこんなに
素晴らしいものがある
そして一番身近な 我が子、
旦那さん、友人
すごく身近に大切に
しなきゃいけない人がたくさんいる
外の情報なんか
どうでもいいと思うんですよ
私は
今回ですね
こちらの登壇を
実はちょっとお断りを 最初
させていただいたんです
私なんかよりももっともっと
本当に損得をかえりみず
子どもたちのために
日々活動している方がたくさん
いらっしゃいます
私がここにいるのは
本当にたまたまなんです
私のことを記事に書いて
SNSにアップしてくださった方
その記事を見て
定置網エバンジェリストの川向さんが
私に声をかけてくださって
本当に宝くじに当たった
ようなものだと私は思っています
でもその運は
たくさん私を
今まで支えてくださった方々の
恩返しのために
使いたいと思って
今こちらに
登壇させていただいております
でも私はやっぱり
人生っていうのは
人を本当に
心から思うエネルギーだけが
すべてだと思うんです
そのことを
愛情と言うのだと思います
その愛情 その愛情が
たっぷり入った「愛情料理」
お母さんの作る「愛情料理」こそが
日本を支える
日本の土台を支える
おだしなのだと
私は思っています
ご静聴ありがとうございました